[Music]
you may have wondered as the world's
biggest industrialized democracies meet
this week to discuss imminent global
crises
who's going to represent the united
states us at this year's g7
summit joe biden can't do it obviously
we don't want to be mean
but you know why he can't he just can't
kamala harris could go but she's tied up
right now getting yelled at by
guatemalan farmers so
who well thankfully there's a doctor in
the house dr
jill the white house publicity team
released this action shot today of dr
jill who we should tell you by the way
is not actually a doctor
hitting the books as she readies herself
to represent america in the global
family of nations
preparing for the g7 reads the caption
she's got a reading glasses on and a pen
in hand
you can see her husband's monogram
jacket on the chair behind her she's
sitting at joe biden's own desk on air
force one so the point
couldn't be clearer dr jill's in charge
now
but what's in the binder that's our
question
what exactly is dr jill reading we can't
say of course we don't have that
clearance
but we can hope that finally after all
these years she is taking the time to
edit her now famous doctoral
dissertation
the one on community colleges in
delaware dr jill apparently was in a
rush when she wrote it the first time
that accounts for the many typos
including the first paragraph of the
introduction
as well as for the unforgettable
sentences like this one
quote according to the retention
director at cecil community college
cecil community college has made a
concerted effort to redress
retention in other words in delaware's
community colleges retention directors
say they're addressing
retention those were dr jill's findings
and they make sense
the question though is could there be a
better way to say it
we'd like to think as she jets above the
atlantic on air force one on the way to
the g7
summit dr jill is searching for just the
right words
good luck dr jill hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else